what is going on there citizens the
reject nation
we are going to watch gravity falls
season two episode 12. johnny
what's it called it's called a tale of
two stans
already guys leave a like that's all we
ask of you today full length reaction
watch along as we sync up with the time
code for gravity falls available over at
our patreon page cover a bunch of shows
over there exclusively at our patreon
where we have the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs included and
thanks to the prepper team for helping
setting down these highlights let's
watch this incredible cliffhanger from
last episode
and proper team thank you thank you
thank you guys i don't think i did thank
you
whoa
neato
mysterious boarded up cave it might be
filmed with lost prehistoric life form
good thing you've got your smarts
poindexter i've got the other thing what
is it called oh right punching
holy moly
oh yeah
it's so creepy in here hey don't worry
bro wherever we go we go together don't
forget to leave our names so they know
who owns the place five pines pines
pines
stanley and stanford
and they are two stands
when i said a tale of two stands i was
like they're both interesting
come on short of that intro
we got a lot of episode of cover
lengthen that intro director's cut
finally after all these long years of
waiting you're actually here
[Music]
changed brother
oh
ow what the heck was that for this was
an insanely risky move restarting the
portal didn't you read my warnings that
jk simmons i think it is jk simmons you
really think i'm gonna thank you after
what you did 30 years ago what i did why
you ungrateful
oh yeah
stan you didn't tell me there were
children down here and some sort of
large hairless gopher
i get that a lot
shermy's grandkids i
i have a niece and nephew they really
are related does anyone else know about
this portal no just us
also maybe the entire us government the
what fan out we're not going anywhere
till we gotta kill them all
gotta kill em all well looks like we're
stuck down here for a while who wants to
tell us their entire mysterious
backstory yes i have some questions
about all this myself stanley a man's is
a lefty
your name is stanford wait you took my
name what have you been doing all these
years your knucklehead yeah uncle stan
no more lies you owe us some answers no
more lies
okay okay okay i know i have a lot of
explaining to do it all started
a lifetime ago 1960-something
as if his abnormally high iq wasn't
enough he also had a rare birth defect
six fingers on each hand which might
have explained his obsession with sci-fi
mystery weirdness he's ambidextrous but
as different as we were we were the
perfect team and every day we'd wander
the beach looking for adventure
look at these two stands ew what's wrong
with you
huh you know what this thing's missing
flags kings of new jersey
oh no
kings of new jersey
iw the stan award ow what the heck well
well if it ain't the loser twins nice
boat you get it at the dump
you jerk
listen dorks and listen good you're a
six-fingered freak and you're just a
dumber sweatier version of him and
you're lucky you have each other because
neither of you will ever make any
friends wow this is like a stephen king
book for the good times those bullies
may have been right about us not making
many friends but when push comes to
shove you only really need one
no
sure i got more than my fair share of
trouble but when your brother's the
smartest kid in school you've always got
a leg up on the competition
[Music]
[Laughter]
till one day
heinz twins to the principal's office
fines twins to the principal's office ah
great what is it this time
not you him
why'd you call the twins then
[Music]
now mr pines i'd like to speak with you
very frankly if i may very frankly is
the only way i speak you have two sons
well it's my garment trap your son may
be a future millionaire mr pines i'm
impressed somebody's got to get paid to
scrape the barnacles off of it
stanford's going places but hey look on
the bright side at least you'll have one
son here in new jersey forever
that is the bright set
if the college board isn't impressed
with my experiment tomorrow then okay
i'll do the treasure hunting thing and
if they are well then i guess you better
come visit me on the other side of the
country
oh no he sabotaged it didn't he don't do
it stan
this is all your fault you dumb machine
oh no oh no no what did i do
[Music]
there all right
good as new probably
[Music]
what have you done
kid a perpetual motion machine has one
job to not stop i don't think you're
west coast tech material no wait don't
go i worked so hard
oh no
all you ever do is lie and cheat and
ride on your brother's coattails well
this time you cost our family potential
millions and until you make us a fortune
you're not welcome in this household
oh
but i had a plan to fix everything
[Music]
oh this story's so sad
unfortunately the treasure hunting
business was slow going apparently gold
is some kind of rare medal
[Laughter]
in sales
hi there i'm stan pines of stanco
enterprises are you sick of this always
happening to you
then you need the chamois
oh no with the same material astronauts
used to clean up cranberry saves on the
moon that's the sham total
it's a total sham
apparently the cheap dye i used to color
them only made stains worse customers
weren't crazy about that
luckily they were chasing me with stanco
brand pitchfork
excellent my whole life i'd been teased
for my six fingers but that got me
thinking about anomalies
things that were odd unusual
statistically improbable and according
to my investigations there was one place
with a higher concentration of these
things than anywhere else
gravity falls meanwhile your old uncle
stan was doing great i'd come up with a
sophisticated new business strategy come
on
owl
football player with an um
[Laughter]
red money to investigate the strange
properties oh my god he built the
mystery check i began to investigate at
once
i knew i'd have to record my findings
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry sorry you just
got excited there about the journals
nerd dipper there were anomalies
everywhere and the more i looked the
more i saw
i realized the only way to understand
gravity falls would be to build a
gateway a portal to the source of its
weirdness i decided to call up my old
college buddy fiddleford mcgucket a
young brilliant mechanic no way
in some garage in palo alto
[Laughter]
an answer to the source of this town's
anomalies
the time had come to test it
oh no
[Music]
when gravity falls and earth becomes sky
fear the beast with just one eye
fiddleford get a hold of yourself you're
not making any sense cipher i can't
destroy this it's my life's work i fear
we've unleashed a grave danger on the
world one i'd just as soon forget fine
i'll do it without you i don't need you
i don't need anyone i'm the doctor
what
who said that
i was in over my head and feared i was
losing my sanity i needed help someone i
could trust
[Music]
you haven't seen your brother in over 10
years it's okay he's family he won't
bite
who is it have you come to steal my eyes
well i can always count on you for a
warm welcome stanley did anyone follow
you anyone at all uh hello to you too
pal
look i've been around the world okay
whatever it is i'll understand
[Music]
there is nothing about this i understand
it's a trans-universal gateway a punched
hole through a weak spot in our
dimension i created it to unlock the
mysteries of the universe start it
take this book get on a boat and sail as
far away as you can to the edge of the
earth
bury it where no one can find it stanley
you don't understand what i'm up against
what i've been through no no you don't
understand what i've been through i've
been to prison in three different
countries i once had to chew my way out
of the trunk of a car
said you wanted me to have it so i'll do
what i want with it my research
[Music]
stanley give it back
open the portal you ruined my life you
ruined your own life
[Music]
stanley oh my gosh i'm so sorry are you
all ow
oh
guys they're turning everything on
stanford
oh stanford come back i didn't mean it
oh that is i just got it back i can't
lose him again
you [ __ ] up you i tried for weeks to
turn that dumb machine back on
but without the other two journals
it was hopeless
just the bread then there stranger
that'll be 99 cents hey that's no
stranger that must be the mysterious
science guy that lived in oh no that's
why he took his name
oh me too do you ever give tours no
really i yes i do give tours 10 no no 15
bucks a person
they all just had that cash ready
step right up folks uh to a world of
enchantment or whatever
behold the um nerdy science box
ah
origins
[Music]
for once in my life people were actually
buying what i was selling and so the
murder hut was born
the murder hut
i faked a car crash to prove it today i
was stanford pines mr mystery by night i
was down in the basement trying to bring
the real stanford back every day
i heard talking it was coming from
downstairs oh no it's too late the
agents are coming for us what do we do i
forgot all about those dudes wait forget
that's it i think i know a way we might
be able to defeat those agents
oh yeah the kill
why am i standing in some sort of goofy
fun knick-knack house i've been sent
with the latest intel from washington
according to this very real report the
power surges in gravity falls were
actually due to radiation
[Music]
ah
great uncle stanford that was amazing
let's not go crazy it was serviceable no
it was amazing it was amazing it's been
a long day and me and my brother have a
lot to talk about so why don't you hit
the hay huh but it's the author i've
been waiting so long to ask questions
about i said
hit the hey don't worry you got like
nine more episodes dip when the summer's
over you give me my house back you give
me my name back and this mystery shack
junk is over forever you got it fine on
one condition you stay away from the
kids i don't want them in danger because
as far as i'm concerned they're the only
family i have left did you hear what
they said i think uncle ford said
they're gonna buy us puppies made of ice
cream
can you promise me you won't get stupid
not stupider than you
dum-dum good night stupid
good night stupid okay okay so it turns
out
[Laughter]
but he's not standing seuss it's three
in the morning okay okay i understand
anyway act two stan started
just hang up
just hang up another horse pretend you
fell asleep wendy
wow
what an episode that was a full-on like
bio
[ __ ] hour yeah
like in a good way
dang yeah that was thick
so much information i know i know so
much necessary information [ __ ] just got
so real i think they'd spread that out
over the course of a couple episodes
instead of taking the extra six minutes
there's a lot like better call saul in
this show
uh oh
huh
why uh oh
it's just the first reaction sound that
came to mind it doesn't make sense
even i don't understand what the uh oh
means because uh unoriginality turns
people off do you think you just need to
make a sound
yes
like how is that [ __ ] come up with
something jay what do you got what do
you got oh my god the date with the show
oh that could be a fun curveball
buddy watson come here come here buddy
um because you better call saul
you have
how howard yeah yeah howard
is it howard michael chuck
chuck
ham you got chuck
and you got
jimmy and chuck is the genius lawyer and
then you got slipping jimmy the brother
saul eventually
and you know he's like the deadbeat but
then the older brother would always take
care of him but then he you know the the
dead beep slipping jimmy never didn't
quite believe him
and then eventually it just led to them
just having its martialis relationship
when all the the the one brother wanted
to do was just slip and jimmy want to
follow in his brother's footsteps
but he could never quite live up to that
image and there's so much about their
comrade just funny that they got
jonathan banks
to tell you the dad because he because
he's in better call saul
and so there's so many similarities i
was noticing about their dynamic
because like he turns into one of them
slipping jimmy one of them is like the
sleazy guy who
people yeah yeah and uh i think that
that back story was really well flushed
out and it
i don't know when they came up with it
but it feels like it's been there this
whole time
yeah in an odd way like even though the
structure of the show hasn't
necessarily like indicated that it does
feel like an integral part of the lore
that now i'm
wondering if you could maybe trace back
even through like the first season where
you wouldn't necessarily expect it you
know
probably i think it has always been
there it kind of seems like it would
have been there from the beginning and
then they flushed it out but yeah to
bring grunkle stan to this point where
he is you know he was always a good guy
essentially like he was a bit conniving
or whatever he had his little uh messed
up plans but he's also kind of uh
he's kind of that uh you know kids club
cover your ears but the best i put is
that that unfortunate [ __ ] up yeah it
was yeah he's a screw-up he's a screw-up
who means well and then doesn't do well
to clean his messes up when he makes
them yeah but he doesn't have a bad
heart for those that he cares about
and watching the origin of the different
paths i went down and what helped them
balance out as brothers was that they
both had a
sense of fun and they ultimately what's
funny about looking at this trajectory
is they ended up achieving the thing
they set out for they went on the
treasure hunts essentially in their own
weird way they discovered these uh
anomalies and these great on life things
maybe they didn't go sailing around the
world together but they
they unpacked some of the greatest
treasures of earth here in gravity falls
and
you know stan it was always kind of
stupid they managed to
figure out the books and get the machine
working took him a few decades but he
eventually got it going and was able to
bring his brother back
yeah so
i like the arc of it but also the note
that they end on where it's like of
course it wouldn't be solved we don't
know what
ford has been up to this whole time and
and what his journey has been while he's
been away but
you know i can't imagine it's been a
super positive time for him but i think
they captured a lot of really exciting
tense notes and uh capturing that 60s
life in the flashbacks
and just the the the spirit and whimsy
and the dramatic
heft and layers while also keeping like
nice
comedy intertwined i thought this was a
really really well done episode
with uh a backstory that was insanely
compelling from beginning to end and
watching how their journeys came to be
here was
very exciting i really love this one i
thought this one was really good like
the last couple episodes have maybe not
been the
funniest episodes but they're not
setting out to be the funniest oh yeah
they are uncovering a lot and doing
different sci-fi tones and i really
think that they
they got these last two have been very
very very special i really enjoyed it a
lot yeah they're super gripping and it's
the right level it's like i appreciate
that because this show does skew a
little bit older like i thought the just
back and forth of their actual you know
brotherly relationship played really
nicely because it's easy to make that
feel trite of like oh come on just like
express your feelings and talk about it
but like the way in which they maintain
the barriers even up to the end but you
can tell where that you know trauma
comes from
yeah it's like it was just enough to
make it feel like you're watching some
kind of actual like a little bit of a
family drama happen but within you know
the sort of whimsical
uh boundaries of the show's style and
aesthetic and they're like so many
wonderful sight gags like throughout the
decades as we're exploring and then to
see it come up to today see how you know
even the regulars of the cast who have
filled out gravity falls kind of
factored in you know you get that little
payoff with mcgucket you know further
expounding on him and two like the
parallel
that they bring for dipper and mabel
because i can't remember what episode it
was but there's an episode you know
further back where
they do kind of come to like a big rift
between the two of them and they feel
like the summer's ruined and you know
they're both growing up and you know
they want to kind of stop that uh
they don't want to end up like these two
and then to bring that back around here
is sort of the end off note for them and
to
leave it where like mabel does just kind
of look like
she's not fully resolved like you know i
feel like in a different show or a more
light show it would be like oh
everyone's gotta be happy by the end um
or at least you know like dipper and
mabel should be happy by the end and
everything's gonna be fine but you know
that actual sort of family nuance of
like things don't always go the way you
want and
love can be harder to communicate than
you think it is when life gets in the
way
uh yeah there's just like so many
wonderful tones alongside all like the
cool fun
uh you know science fiction stuff like
you mentioned and like they're good at
making that stuff feel like actually
kind of intense you know like when
when uh
they're starting up the machine and
everything like even though that's all
in the past you're like oh man this does
seem like a you know
something that could like rip the world
apart and uh yeah it's like a really
the mystery and the stakes feel very
alive you know despite all the whimsy
and a lot of great new jersey jokes
yeah
uh yeah all right guys that's great
gravity falls you've done it again
waiting for the next one journey's
coming to a close now it's been the best
it's ever been
but thank you guys for joining us on
this journey uh subscribe leave a like
and let's end this with a patreon
david gandy you know you got us gravity
falls apparel and we're not wearing any
of that dude but your book is
dude the journal unfortunately not it's
actually just cut off right off from
journal it's right
journals right over there
and we were told not to flip through it
because there could be spoilers in it so
we have to wait yeah but it's actually
it is right next to that batman right
over there we're getting into the zone
where we could maybe actually read the
journal now one of these days yeah and
david i hope you are going on some
adventures and you did send me a message
that uh i just figured i'd answer on
camera here oh good yeah yeah um
but text it you know um let's see here
hey uh have you ever used anamorphic
lenses to get a more cinematic look over
the spherical photographic lenses
not here for this channel b h has a 50
millimeter f 1.8 for sony on sale
and uh dave was thinking about getting
it oh that sounds like a great idea i
mean you could report back to us with
your findings because i mean here in the
studio we don't really have a reason to
shoot anamorphic but uh
because i feel like anamorphic i think
is uh like extra wide you know
get the black bars and stuff i feel like
that leave a little less room for like
footage of reactions and whatnot but out
in the filmmaking world and the
photography world i think it's a great
idea and you should swipe that lens up
no
send okay
well
you know david
much like the pines brothers uh you know
life finds a way we we all make our
choices and then live with the fallout
so
david can you put those lenses hope
you're having some awesome adventures
out in arizona enjoy that new comfy
house talk with you soon buddy
[Music]